hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game that was played this year
in the practice Festival in the
challengers Edition between Han smoke
and Neiman and Max farmerdam we've seen
a lot of his games on this channel
already uh there's the the famous Queen
sacrifice one if you still haven't seen
it do check it out you know just search
the best Queen sacrifice of 2021 uh I
think the the title was something like
that but before we check out this game
and you will enjoy it it's a spectacular
game a a truly a remarkable attack was
Unleashed so many pieces were offered so
many pieces of sacrifice that you will
not believe if it's even possible to
survive such an attack but before we
check it out I would just like to
mention that regarding everything that's
been happening in the Chess World uh
Gary Kasparov made a nice statement he
there's an interview regarding what's
been going on I will put a link in the
description below so you can watch it at
some 10 minutes so if you have the time
you can hear them's thoughts on the
whole situation and another thing Fida
is long launching an official
investigation in what happened in the in
the cross and Neiman situation here for
those of you who are interested that's a
niche uh this is the uh statement Fida
gave following uh by the fair play
commission following the recent
developments in the Carlson Neiman
controversy fideous fair play commission
has decided to ex to act ex-officio
meaning that's Latin for by virtue of
the office and create an investigatory
panel three members of the commission
will form this panel and it will also
have the possibility to call for a
consultation with external experts when
uh wherever analysis is required and the
focus of the investigation would be
twofold checking the world Champion's
claims of alleged cheating by Neiman and
the Neiman's self-statement regarding
online cheating as stated by Fairplay
chairs person Salome azaksite the fair
play uh FPL I don't know what an FPL is
maybe the fair play league or something
is ready to examine the circumstances
census compile and analyzed all the data
and evidence available and a certain the
facts and allegations that have been
made public the panel will ensure a fair
ruling protecting the rights of both
parties during the investigation in the
best interest of the chess Community we
would kindly ask the public to refrain
from speculations on the outcomes and
potential sanctions until all available
facts are well considered and a proper
investigation is finalized added by Dr
zaksete so there you have it this is the
official statement by fide what will
happen how long will it take for them to
perform this official investigation we
will we will see I will keep you guys
informed but now let's check out this
game as this is what we do on this
channel now Hans has the white pieces
and he opens with Pawn to D4 this was
played in round three of this year's
practice Festival Challengers Edition
and also I apologize for pieces not
having sound for the past few videos I
have no idea what what happened but in
the volume settings
um the the browser volume was set to
really like a minimum so I don't know
how long this was going on I've seen
some of you were commenting um on this
but I just thought it was a you know
something that has to do with your own
device so today I checked and it seems
no it was uh on my end so I apologies
for that yeah or sorry about that as we
send this channel uh but okay Hans plays
D4 we have Pawn to D5 C4 we have E6 and
now Knight to C3 Pawn to C5 by Max uh
going for the tarash defense C captures
on D5 and now we often say that there
are two ways to play this e Captain D5
which rarely leads the you know some
fancy play and C captures on D4 which
often leads to some crazy position so
Queen the A4 check Bishop to D7 and now
queen recaptures queen captures on D4 E
Capture Sun D5 the only series attempt
black has Queen captures and D5 and now
Knight to F6 so if you count the pawns
black is down upon but he's getting some
a very nice rapid development Queen back
to D1 and now Bishop the C5 uh further
developing pieces Knight F3 and Max
castles here and if you look at the
position now Max is down upon but Hans
King is still on E1 and he still needs
to play at least three moves to Castle
and that's uh well that could um that's
easier said than done so here Pawn to A3
and now we have Knight the C6 we have
Bishop to G5 and now uh there are a
couple of games that reach this position
but here after H6 it is now as of move
11 that we have a completely new game so
what is the idea behind H6 the idea is
to start a spectacular uh flurry of
moves that start with Bishop captures
and F6 it seems like you can't play
Queen captures because of Queen captures
on D7 but that's exactly what Max does
he plays Queen captures on F6 gives up
the bishop on D7 and look at this now
Queen captures on D7 and now Rook after
d8 attacking the queen queen back to G4
the only good square and not Knight the
E5 and it seems like like that's it game
over how can you resist this attack of
course the Knight cannot be captured
because just bishop or queen captures
will be Checkmate as The Rook covers the
entire D file but uh Hans finds the
absolute best Queen to G3 now preparing
the the gobble of the Knight but uh just
Queen to B6 Max offers the the full
Knight here and okay you can see that
there could be some problems here Queen
captures and B2 attacks The Rook attacks
tonight so maybe it's not the best time
to capture that Knight hunts place the
absolute best Rook to B1 and now how do
you continue this uh one way to continue
would be to play Knight to G4 it comes
with the same idea of course that the
Knight cannot be captured because the
bishop captures an FD Checkmate uh point
is that you will have to play E3 and
then let's say Bishop captures an E3 F
captures Knight captures on E3 and now
how do you play this you still have to
play
two more moves before you can Castle but
you can't even Castle you can't touch
the F1 Square you can't go to F2 because
the queen covers that so all sorts of
nasty discoveries become possible uh you
would maybe have like a bishop to B5 but
still after a sex Bishop to A4 uh it
seems that white is better but who who
would play this I mean what do you do
with this King here the King has no
squares it's it's such an ugly position
to play uh but again it's not easy to
find attacking moves for black you can't
play B5 to take away the eight Square
from the rook and um it's uh well it's a
beautiful position but instead uh
instead of this Knight to G4 idea Rook 8
to C8 and what is this now now can the
Knight be captured now and what is Rook
8 to C8 even accomplishing well many
things now I will just show you what
happens if Knight captures an E5 if
Knight captures an E5 then many things
become possible one of them is just
Bishop characters on A3 and now you
might be thinking but why what is this
if I just capture the bishop isn't my
knight defending the Rook of course it
is but just Queen captures on B1 check
Knight captures and now Rook the C1 is
Checkmate now you realize what Max did
by playing Rook 8 to C8 he set up this
beautiful Checkmate so everything is
still in the position so if uh if Hans
even wanted to play this he would have
to find the move like F4 which is uh I
mean it's it's silly to even look at
allow Rook captures on C3 and now play B
captures on C3 Queen captures on B1 with
check King F2 Bishop to C5 with check E3
now Rook the detail with check King F3
and after Queen to D1 check put the King
on e4
and this this will be possible of course
and I mean it's
uh you don't see something like this
every day if for example a vastly
ventric was playing with the white
pieces you might Imagine a King on e4
but uh here most likely there's
something like Queen B1 King back here
and a nice draw by repetition of moves
would occur but still who knows I mean
it's it's a it's a not your everyday
chest position so here uh E3 was played
by Hans keeping everything alive and now
just the bishop captures on A3 and this
is a another beautiful move by Max
because if you go for Bishop captures on
E3 uh hunt actually calculated this
perfectly because after F characters and
The Rook captures and C3 now seemingly
okay B captures runs into Queen captures
on B1 there's Knight D4 now you are
preventing Rook captures on E3 but look
at this now Rook captures on D4 and
after Queen captures an E5 how do you
continue this uh it seems like rookie 4
is possible because now uh the queen
gains access to D3 square and it seems
like black is breaking through but look
at this queen captures anif for white
happily gives up a queen and if Rook
captures Queen captures Queen captures
there's Bishop P2 and all of a sudden
Hans has two Rooks and a bishop against
the queen he would be winning this game
so instead after E3 Max plays the
absolute best Bishop captures on A3 and
now uh how do you continue this game
well we have to Castle Bishop to B5
luckily the Knight is guarding the
bishop so you don't have to worry about
that and next move hopefully you will
Castle uh problem is uh you cannot play
A6 here if you play A6 here then Queen
captures on E5 becomes possible because
now uh how are you how are you dealing
with with this bishop if you capture it
then we just capture an A3 and the Queen
no longer is attacking The Rook here so
you could play something like Rook the
C5 attack the queen and the bishop now
Queen to E7
and if Rook captures on C3 opening up an
attack towards the queen we just
captured B captures an A3 and if a
captures on B5 now white can castle and
now if you count everything uh Hans
would simply be up a full night of
course you cannot allow this so Bishop
captures on B2 this was the idea of when
Max captured an A3 so now it seems like
white is finally falling apart but here
Hans just castles and now okay
everything gets traded off Knight
captures an F3 with check Queen captures
now Rook captures on C3 Rook characters
on B2 and finally A6 preventing the
Bishop from moving because the Rook now
will hang and beat you and now while a
lot of moves are possible here like
Queen the H5 can be played Queen to eat
you can be played the the bishop will
fall Hans decides to give the queen his
win and he plays Queen captures on F7
with check giving him an equal Rook end
game but he will have four to two um
advantage on on the king side uh
regarding pawns and now after King
captures on F7 Bishop to C4 with check
winning back the queen Rook captures on
C4 and now Rook captures on B6 and now
after all of that Madness that I mean
was sort of impossible to calculate we
have this Elementary Rook end game where
board both parties have two Rooks uh and
uh both parties have uh four pawns but
it's um two points on the queen side
versus zero pawns on the queen side so
if a Max can start pushing those pawns
it will be very interesting but also
Hans has four to two on the king side so
if the that pawn majority starts
marching forward it could get very
unpleasant for the black king so let's
see how they play this out to Rook to D7
of course the pawn here must be
protected Rook F to B1 piling up on the
B7 pawn and now Rook to C7 and here Hans
just plays G4 he wants to play f4h for
bringing the king up the board and uh
Max has to figure out how to uh play
anything because for them moment the
Rooks are stuck here guarding the B7
Pawn so he figures it out of course the
king will come to C8 and then the rook
and the King will be guarding the B7
Pawn so you will be able to activate at
least one Rook soaking the E8 with King
to G2 King to d8 and now H4 King to C8
now the Rooks can be activated Rook won
the B3 and now Rook to C4 putting
pressure on the pawns here so Pawn to F4
and now A5 starting to push that pass
Pawn
uh it can come to A4 it will be defended
there but unless you have a rook behind
it it will be somewhat difficult to push
it so here we have Rook 6 to B5 going
after the pawn Rook the A4 still it's
defended here but now just to Rook the
A3 preparing Rook to A5 to really uh win
that pawn so here Rook to D6 and now uh
Hans plays King to F3 he could also try
Rook to A5 right away but uh as B6 was
not played and uh well Rook the D6 kind
of announces that if you play Rook day 5
that Rook to A6 will be played Max uh
sorry Hans takes advantage of this and
he plays King to F3 uh you know if
everything gets traded off your king
will be one step closer to where it
needs to be so here King the C7 and this
is a uh one moment where maybe B6 would
have done a a better job preventing Rook
to A5 and also the pawn is nicely
protected there but then you have to
worry about Rook F5 with some ideas like
check and winning the G7 Pawn but still
Rook F6 and let's say if Rook D5 D7
stops rookie 7 and it's a fine position
but okay it's uh I mean both Rooks are
still on the board it's very hard to
play Perfect move so King to C7 and now
Rook to A5 goes after the pawn marks
defenses Rook to A6 and now just a rook
capture spawn captures and now Rook to
D3 so now uh from that position that was
pretty pretty equal now you have this
position where hunt still has this Pawn
Mass on the king side and there are two
pawns on the queen side but they are no
longer two um uh two connected passports
now you do have a pass Pawn but they are
uh they are double the double Pawn so
here King to B6 if you could put the
Rook on A5 and start pushing those pawns
that'd be great but uh you you're just
not in time for that so King B6 Now Pawn
to E4 and now uh again if you try
something like Rook C5 to go after this
uh you can just push E5 and 4K 5 just D6
and you can't stop the pawn and you you
are far too late to push your own point
you cannot go anywhere near the king
because the Rook cuts off the entire D
file so this would be easily winning so
here we have Rook to C1 now um uh Max
will try to check the white king and
also put the rook and A1 to start
advancing the fast Pawn we have E5 now
and here comes Rook to A1 now uh this
can be played uh many different ways but
let's say you play Rook to E1 you simply
want to prevent the E6 then Rook to D4
is very strong because it goes after the
A4 pawn and also it takes away the E4
Square from the black Rook now your your
idea is that that okay if the King goes
to A5 to defend the pawn I'm just gonna
play King F2 kick away The Rook uh as
all of these squares will be covered by
the rook and king and then I'm gonna
start pushing a F5 E6 and so on and it's
not easy to uh to to find a move here
and it's very important if you play
rookie 3 of course just captures
captures and now the d a pawn is winning
so a move like Rook to D4 is much needed
and now let's say Rook to A1 uh now you
continue King E4 and after A3 you play
uh Rook to D2 you want to put the Rook
on E2 but also guard that A2 pawn and it
would be very very difficult for uh for
black to deal with this if Rook to B1
you're gonna play Rook to A2 and now if
Rook to B4 would check you're gonna play
King to F5 and if G6 King captures uh
Rook captures on F4 but now just Pawn to
E6 and again black is in a in a lot of
trouble so very very complicated stuff
but in the game Rook the A1 was played
and this allows um uh Hans to play this
very nice Rook the E3 move he's now
preparing to push the pawn pawn the A3
and now King the E4 this King the E4 is
very very important uh because if you
just start pushing the pawn then you
allow Ponte A2 and if E7 then Rook to F1
check you clear the the A1 square with
check and now A1 Queen will be very good
for you A1 Queen White also gets a queen
but you're the one that starts checking
first and of course uh no more winning
for white so Hans plays King to E4 very
very important not allowing any checks
from the black Rook A2 and now Rook to
E2 again the only winning uh move by
white you have to keep an eye on that A2
Pawn so The Rook cannot move for free so
here G6 taking away the F5 Square now
comes Pawn to E6 with King to C7 and now
King the E5 again not allowing any
checks and here we have King to d8 uh
leaving uh this uh a very very
interesting rook and pawn and game game
where only one move is winning for Hans
so I don't want to you know leave you
guys hanging without a pause the video
moment so uh you know brush up on your
endgame skill feel free to pause the
video and to win this game for Hunts uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on going for that
pawn push and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
spawn to F5 Ponte H5 is also interesting
as the black will have to deal with a
lot of problems if like if G captures
then the F5 Pawn comes about the F5 is
just very straightforward and very very
winning and this is what Hans played if
you thought about King the F6 which is
of course also possible this would not
work this is a big problem because now
Rook to F1 and you no longer have a win
because now A1 is becoming a queen of
course if you push E7 chicken and King
to E8 and again you have this problem
and the F4 Pawn is hanging so here once
uh the pawns get traded off just Rook
captures an F4 check King capture
sanjisa through captors and G4 check and
now if Rook F6 you just play real
characters on H4 you don't care because
white is never winning this King E8 Rook
captures an A6 now looks very good by
The Rook to F4 check is the problem and
now if you move uh the king towards the
Rook uh doesn't really matter Rook F7
goes after the pawn if you try to defend
your Pawn just rookie for check also the
pawn Falls uh so you you've squandered
your advantage away so Pawn to F5 is the
way to go g captures an F5 G captures
and now King to E7 we have Pawn to F6
check King to f8 E7 check we have King
to F7 and here Hans just played King to
D6 and he was in this position on move
48 that max volume resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here my
point is that after you play this Rook
to D1 check yes you are bringing a queen
into the game but it doesn't matter
after King to C6 okay you get a queen
but now uh this uh Queen comes into the
game with check and that's a problem
you're getting checkmated King captures
and F6 Rook F2 check you force the black
king into a corner King G7 Queen E7
check and out regardless of where the
King goes it's gonna be mating one let's
say queen to F6 uh trackmate uh F7
Checkmate as the pawn covers the G5
Square
so truly a remarkable game where uh Max
Unleashed a brilliant brilliant attack I
mean he he just started sacrificing
everything right right from the start
when uh I mean even uh right here after
this H6 move which is a incredibly
provocative just you know giving up that
D7 Bishop I mean what what a move I mean
and if you look at the king here you
still have to move the pawn the bishop
you have to Castle so many moves uh and
somehow it uh you know uh hunt was able
to survive this what what an incredible
attack by by Max but what an incredible
defense by by Hans taking it into sort
of an equal end game but even though the
end game is equal uh it does it does not
matter that it's um uh you know easy to
play Both Sides because okay someone
would prefer to have four points on one
side someone would prefer to have two
connected pass pawns on the queen set
but you've seen how even though you know
you you they teach you as a child or
even you know if you start um learning
about just as an adult that you know
past Bonds on the side of the board are
very very strong and if you have them in
the end game usually you will have many
winning chances but here there was just
no good way to activate them there was
no good way to put a rook behind the
pass pawn and without that it's very
very hard to push them
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it another big congratulations
to everyone who spotted this um a
wonderful idea after King today just
spawn to F5 is winning uh so yeah we'll
see what what will happen how will the
video commission uh the defeated
Fairplay commission react uh to
everything what will they find in the
what kind of a decision will they make
and of course what consequences
will those decisions yield we can only
wait and see but I will keep you guys
informed so you know just keep enjoying
your day and like I said if you haven't
seen the game between
um uh the one that I've mentioned from
2021 I think I named it greatest Queen
sacrifice of 2021. do check it out okay
I will I will put a link to it in the
description below if you you know don't
want to search if you just want to click
it so yeah enjoy it it's quite quite a
nice nice game uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I I would
like to thank Henry's Prague and Sarah
of medrata Michael ovens ravishing
reptiles YouTube and James Duran Lubbock
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot I really appreciate it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and I just
remembered I forgot to show you the
standings uh those are not the standings
my bad uh
there we go these are the standings of
the of the process Festival as you can
see Hans and Vincent camera finished on
six and a half out of nine but Hans
played a very very fighting tournament
he had five wins one loss and three
draws whereas Vincent had four wins zero
draws zero losses and five draws
followed by Abu satro of uh with three
win zero draws and zero losses and six
draws and so on and so on so quite a
nice game and quite a nice tournament by
by Neiman uh so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day